when I say standard forms this parabola
here is just one version it's a concave
up parabola right but there's other
kinds of parabolas too we'll just start
by reiterating this guy
so if you see x squared equals 4a Y you
can draw your set of axes you know this
guy is going to have it's no I missed
but you get the idea yeah it's gonna
have its vertex there at the origin it's
gonna have its directrix down here at y
equals negative a and its focus up here
at 0 comma a but I can just as easily
have a downward facing parabola right so
this is concave up concave down oops I
need some space would have what kind of
equation a concave down parabola x
squared would be equal to maybe for a Y
or you could put the minus on the other
side it doesn't really matter so I'm
gonna write minus for a Y here okay it's
worth noting since a is a length a is
always positive so I should probably
state that yeah a is greater than 0
because it's a focal length after all so
in order to get a concave down parabola
you have to put a minus sign on the
outside this is the shape of course we
would get but now my directrix and my
focus are all swapped around right the
directrix is not going to be underneath
the parabola the direction is going to
be above and pushing the parabola facing
it downwards right so you can see it's
equation would not be y equals negative
a its equation would be just positive a
conversely your focus is not going to be
above your parabola it's going to be
beneath so therefore it's coordinates
down here would be 0 negative a okay so
we've got concave up concave down we've
known that this could happen for a long
time but now is the time where we
formally introduce it concave up and
concave down or not the
the directions on our Cartesian plane we
can of course have concave left and
concave writes how would we make things
face left right instead of up down what
would we do
yeah if I swapped my variables I'm
swapping what we think of as horizontal
with what we think I was vertical so if
I said y squared equals 4a X instead of
the other way around then when you draw
this is this one going to be concave
left or concave right this will be
concave right how did you know because
right sounds positive well right doesn't
just sound positive on the x-axis right
is positive by definition right so see
over here see over here how on the left
hand side you got a square so Y has to
be the lowest it can be a zero and it's
going to go up do you agree so here
you've got a square on the left hand
side so the smallest X can be is zero
and everything else is positive so I can
get my concave right from there where's
the directrix going a bit the directrix
is what pushes the parabola away so I'm
going to position it over here on the
left okay it's a vertical line not a
horizontal line so it's not going to be
ye cause it'll be x equals and being on
the left hand side of the Cartesian
plane it must be minus a that of course
positions your focus over here but
because it's going left right instead of
up down it's going to be the
x-coordinate the changes yeah so it's
gonna be a comma zero so I've got
concave up concave down concave right
and here comes concave left to complete
the picture
okay now there's more things to have a
look at under this ID and lots more but
this is enough for you to have a think
about oh by the way I need to ask you
about this why this is important the
latus rectum have a look at it for a
second we can work out the length of
this now because we know what the
equation of this parabola is if it's x
squared equals 4a y x squared equals 4a
y what will these coordinates be how
would you go about working out what
those coordinates are this is x squared
equals one honest question what I'm
trying to do is I'm trying to find the
coordinates of these two spots on either
ends of this interval how do I find them
based on the geometry here in this
equation
[Music]
Sharon you'll have a shot so you can see
therefore that it has to be in line with
the focus which has a y-coordinate a so
this must be something a and this is
something a so I can find out what the
something is by saying okay well x
squared equals 4a squared do you agree I
just substituted in so therefore to find
those X values I just take the square
root of both sides so I get plus or
minus 2a does that make sense
so over here minus 2a and over here 2 a
so the length of the latus rectum no
matter how big or which direction this
parabola is facing in is always exactly
four times longer than your focal length
okay and you can actually verify that by
measurement when you actually draw it
you can do whatever probably you like
you'll find it okay